welcome to hannity tonight we are
tracking multiple major stories
including president biden's upcoming
trip to saudi arabia now in 2019 then
candidate in the basement bunker joe
biden vowed to make saudi arabia pay the
price for killing the journalist jamal
khashoggi and he referred to saudi's
crown prince as a pariah proclaimed
quote there's very little social
redeeming value in the present
government of saudi arabia all right joe
when you go to saudi arabia you're going
to stand up and say it right to his face
right to the crown prince's face are you
going to make him pay the price like you
promised or will joe biden get on his
knees and beg and plead and ham and haul
for oil that he's unwilling to drill
here for in america the answer is likely
obvious we'll have a lot more on this
with former secretary of state mike
pompeo along with a look into saudi
arabia's attempt to cleanse their toxic
image a multi-billion dollar golf
tournament featuring record-setting
payouts to major american golfers and
also tonight newly unearthed audio that
has been extracted from the laptop from
hell shows hunter biden bragging in his
own voice about the influence he has
over his father we got that tape
straight ahead also we are monitoring
primary results in four states south
carolina north dakota nevada maine along
with a runoff in texas we'll keep you
posted on the numbers as they come in
tonight and thankfully the midterms are
only five months away and we have a
chance to stop the devastating policies
of joe biden now with democrats running
the entire show in the washington swamp
this country is now barreling into what
will be a prolonged period of economic
pain economic suffering the national
average for a gallon of gas is up yet
again for the 18th straight day now well
over five bucks a gallon nationally
that's the average diesel much higher at
nearly six dollars we'll have a lot more
on this tonight and naturally inflation
is also still on the rise the stock
market meanwhile is plunging
dramatically uh guess what we're back to
where joe started on day one the dow
jones well average down another 150
points today what is that five days in a
row significant declines four out of the
five and tomorrow could likely be much
worse the fed expected to once again
raise interest rates either a half point
or a massive three-quarters of a point
interest rate hike and will continue to
hike rates for the foreseeable future
goldman sachs predicts as many as 11 in
the next two years combined and that
means well new home sales will go down
new home construction yet that's about
to come to a standstill sales of
existing homes will plummet home values
sorry i know many of you got recently
gotten valuations they will head south
fast too as well remember the higher the
rate that means fewer loans that means
fewer americans that will be out there
buying houses now combine that with the
spiking inflation spiking gas prices
this country we are all headed into a
very scary place already two-thirds of
the country is living paycheck to
paycheck a former obama economic advisor
i don't always agree with him but he's
been right on every item up to this
point as it relates to biden's economy
lawrence summers predicted that a
recession is imminent in the next year
or two and remember summers was the one
that accurately corrected the
administration predicting that the
current inflation crisis uh was in fact
real when they were saying it was only
transitory so now with everything
imploding around them well joe biden
your president is outraged not about the
economy he seems to think that his
economic policies are a historic success
no today joey was mad at you we the
american people for complaining about
the inflation his economic and energy
policies caused he mad at us why are you
mad at me joe take a look
i don't want to hear any more of these
lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
joey's mad he's all animated today joey
must have taken he must have his
wheaties this morning
in fairness it wasn't just biden's
out-of-control spending that caused
inflation it was joe's war on the oil
and gas industry on behalf of of course
the climate alarmist cult that is the
new greendale socialist party that he is
beholden to and by the way i keep coming
back to oil and gas why because energy
independence is the single number one
best thing that we can do
to bring down the costs at the pump and
lower diesel prices you lower diesel
prices that lowers the price of every
item you buy at every store you shop at
and that's not going to happen this
administration they put their priority
on the climate alarmist cult not on you
we the american people you know just
listen to what biden's climate czar the
john curry had to say on friday take a
look
energy security where he is driving a
lot of the thoughts now about oh we need
more drilling of gut we need more
trolling in this we need to go back to
coal no we don't
we absolutely don't
and we have to prevent a false narrative
from entering into this or
again
pun intended we are cooked
all right kerry like every kerry like
everyone else in the climate cult wants
gas prices to be high it
all is a means to an end they want you
to consume less energy they want you to
travel less they want you to they want
to force you to buy an electric car and
just last week biden's energy secretary
jennifer granholm said that americans
could save money on gas by purchasing a
60 000 electric car everybody got an
extra 60 grand laying around i think we
need to hire deep programmers for these
uh climate obsessed cult maniacs this
climate socialist cult has so
indoctrinated all of them they have lost
every bit of common sense that they ever
had if they ever had any the simple
answer we have a solution go back to the
trump policies of energy independence
that would mean they would need to green
light the keystone xl pipeline we can
get 900 000 barrels of canadian oil a
day that'll help lower the price at the
pump uh that's an easy one the alberta
premiere said it would be done by now if
joe didn't put a restriction on it now
we can lift the exploration ban that he
put in place in anwar we can end joe
biden's paws on new oil and gas drilling
permits on federal land and we can get
out of the paris climate accords which
oh that's right china and india are
called developing nations and pay
little to no money and we pay the bulk
of the of the monies and meanwhile we've
reduced carbon emissions more than any
other country in the industrialized
world and by the way he can also joe can
lift restrictions that he put on
fracking we can create enough natural
gas that we can start providing our nato
allies and western european friends with
all the natural gas that they need and
they won't be making vladimir putin rich
again guess what that will uh help end
the war with ukraine
joe biden would rather flat out lie
though about our economic woes that he
caused take a look
since i took office to your help
families are carrying less debt
nationwide
they have more savings nationwide
that's not true at all take a look at
your screen this is from cnbc quote
americans now have an average of nine
thousand dollars less in savings than
they did last year according to news
nation quote as inflation goes up so
does america's credit card debt joe
biden his entire administration they are
living in a fantasy world just listen to
what white house press secretary you
know out there touting
get this america's historically good
economy now think about that is this
historically good to you how do you feel
when you fill up your tank how do you
feel when you go to the grocery store
how do you feel when you go to lowe's
and home depot how do you feel when you
go to the drugstore even mcdonald's is
charging a lot more they have no choice
take a look
economists do cite the war in ukraine
and supply chain issues we did have that
before the war supply chain issues they
also say that last year's stimulus
package which you mentioned contributed
to inflation korean does the biden
administration bear some responsibility
for this
so first of all
the american rescue plan met the moment
and it has put us in a place where we
can actually uh uh put us in a place
where the american people feel
can can actually we can take on
inflation
by the way karine sean pierre was not
expecting tough questions from fake news
cnn this administration is such a
disaster now even don lemon hardcore
liberal is actually following our lead
and questioning joe biden's mental and
physical abilities wow little late but
welcome to the party take a look does
the president have the stamina
physically and mentally do you think to
continue on even after 2024.
you're asking me this question oh my
gosh he's the president of the united
states you know he i can't even keep up
with it we just got back from new mexico
we just got back from california uh that
is
i
i
that is not a question that we should be
even asking
not a question we should be asking the
guy that can barely put two coherent
sentences together and can i call the
bluff on this she can't keep up with joe
biden um
i'm not buying that the guy gets blown
over by the wind walking up the stairway
to air force one the guy who gets up
late goes to bed early a guy that called
the lid at 2 p.m today
don you might as well say it joe biden
is weak frail and a cognitive wreck and
you can add if you want to be fair we
were way ahead of the curve you can say
and sean hannity on fox news was right
the whole time now sadly the democratic
party is not in good hands joe biden is
asleep at the wheel while radical
extreme socialists are driving the car
today some of them tried to block a bill
providing more security for u.s supreme
court justices this of course after last
week's assassination attempt against
justice kavanaugh which by the way was
not mentioned on any sunday show except
fox news sunday now the bill eventually
did pass 396 to 27. by the way look at
the 27 names right there all 27 no votes
came from democrats including a lot of
squad members aoc was in there
congresswoman to leave was in there
anyway um we they even went as far as to
doxing the children's school of amy
coney barrett this after the
assassination
uh well attempt was discovered by law
enforcement hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else